one
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Friday or should I say
happy
Gotta Get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the stripes Bros
that's right it is Friday
congratulations you guys but more
importantly it's stride day we've got
the stress Bros in the studio with us
which is now just like a regular thing
you know it's not even like a big deal
anymore no it's really not a big deal
and I'm gonna miss it when they no
longer attend when we're remote it's
very sad because it's like we're
together I don't really need this Joy I
suppose because I have you and it's so
sweet yeah when um
hey don't wanna be that was good
by myself
and that's when I need to try sand to
come to his mommy so I hope everyone's
having a great stride day so far whether
it's with their stress bro or even by
yourself because sometimes being by
yourself is kind of everything yeah oh
you know what I did last night do you
remember when we took a vacation over
the summer and Margo made us watch this
Jennifer Garner movie that like no one
was into we watched the first two movies
and we stopped the first two minutes and
we stopped watching a funeral yeah it's
called Catch and Release but Margo came
into my room last night and we wanted to
watch a movie and like for some reason
that movie like was in my mind as like a
snatchler-associated film and we watched
it we still have 20 minutes left which
is like crazy but Ben came home and like
we were in my bed and he was like Margo
get out of my bed so we still have 20
minutes off but it was a cute movie like
really cute it's Catch and Release with
Jennifer Garner nice last night I
started the redheads book I had to put
down my other book because I'm cutting
it close now redhead's book is Hester
and it's very spooky season
Salem Massachusetts we haven't really
even spoken about how we're currently
existing in spooky season it's not a big
deal for us because we pretty much live
24 7 365 in spooky season it's true
so like no but like I don't need to
because like your neighbors have put up
like different things and there's candy
everywhere like the spooky season is so
upon us yeah it's really spooky week and
I still don't think um I guess it's
Friday and Monday's Halloween okay so I
guess starting today you can wear a
Halloween costume but if you did it any
other day before then you were just
dressing up unless you dressed up as
Jackson Claude in which case your
beautiful stunning and smart and
everything you do is perfect we got a
lot of people dressing up as up as us
and Halloween has not started right I
woke up this morning I guess last night
because it was Thursday like people
started going out for Halloween and I
got tagged in like so many
um costumes of us which is so flattering
yeah and you know if you need a late
last minute costume you need like a red
wig some pajamas and a stuffed animal
and merch yeah which you probably
already have yeah speaking of
morningtoast.com we launched a new
collection yesterday well it was an old
and a new collection because our iconic
our staple crewnecks the sororities
crewnecks were restocked and we launched
a new a new little item for The Mamas
some baby onesies for boys and girls
that just really took at the
heartstrings they really do shop
morningtoast.com check it out
um
what did I want to say
you know I think we're being silenced on
Tick Tock what do you mean so she did
peruse your profile last night so last
night I uploaded a tick tock um I
clipped our conversation of our thoughts
on Taylor being silenced and just
trigger warnings in general which a lot
of people seem to agree with and I
thought it'd be like a good take people
could have interesting conversation in
the comments and before I went to bed
like it's blowing up it's like doubling
views it went from like 50 to 100 to 120
in the span of a couple minutes so I'm
like oh my god when I wake up it's gonna
be like a million so when I went to bed
it was at 120 and then I woke up this
morning and it was at 1 30. like I'm
we're being silenced we stopped in its
tracks somebody didn't like what we had
to say at TT headquarters
that's the thing about TT it's all fun
and games until they don't like what you
have to say you know it's often a game
until you're being silenced right you
feel like Bethany yet
no although I did have a thought last
night when I was making popcorn for the
movie with Margot we did make the skinny
girl
um microwave popcorn which is supreme
like I'm sorry it is so it's great it's
the perfect quantity it's the perfect
quality it's not flavors buttery or
salty but it has flavor it's not totally
skinny and Bland it's really good like
it's the perfect it's personal size but
you could also share with a friend if
you're feeling generous thank God Margo
wasn't in the mood so I really had it
all to myself and it popped it in
correctly so I made about four pieces
however I just I thought it would only
be right that I come on here and say
like well Bethany maybe one of the most
annoying people on social media she
makes a good popcorn like really really
good yeah stunning yeah perfect the
other popcorn sometimes I'm like you
know what I want something really
buttery and it's for some reason like
it's just not good either it's too big
or it's too small or it's not even that
buttery I just hers is a constant that's
why you always need to have on hand I
Can't Believe It's Not Butter spray I
think I do have it because you need more
butter Spritz Spritz
Society just go toast
um so we've got a Fab show no TV recap
but just interesting stories interesting
girls which is so important you know
that you'd be interesting especially
when you have a Peabody award-winning
podcast
yeah it's kind of important just a
little
uh we actually do have a good story so I
guess without further Ado it's Friday
like you know it's Halloween weekend I'm
sure everyone's yeah
honestly like an office Halloween party
if there is one it's probably this
afternoon oh no would it be on Monday I
feel like Friday's more of an office
party Vibe and so we gotta get through
to send you off we won't take up too
much of your time but do know that this
is the last episode before Jax and I
unveil our 2022 right toaster Halloween
costume we are both really excited we
still have to run to Party City or
Spirit Halloween today today yeah
there's things you're gonna sell out
yeah no you're right we should go today
we have the bulk of the costumes but you
know the accoutrement as stated yeah I'm
not crazy about my wig like you're aware
you're wrong for that I'll wear it but
if I can find a better one at Spirit
Halloween so yeah we need some
accoutrement and we'll we'll go today
because you're right we don't want to
get last legs that's so awesome so
you'll see Jackson Cloud again on
Tuesday because Jackson Claude are not
going to be here on Monday blank and
blank are going to be here on Monday
blank and blank and blankety blank will
be here right the boys are the stress
Bros are of course involved in the
costume and I'm I'm really excited I
also haven't really thought much I have
to like sit down and think about the
angle I'm gonna put on my character like
me too I really have to go method for
this yeah because my character is like
potentially a little nefarious
potentially it just depends you know
yeah so I won't give too much away but
I'm I'm thrilled I'm excited I kind of
like forgot I have a lot going on next
week
test I'll be I'll be driving Jackie to
her permit test on when is it Tuesday
yeah like what am I gonna wear
that's what I was gonna say oh my god do
you take a picture I think
do you yeah because you got to get a
permit card oh right and then I believe
that's the one they use for your license
so I need to maybe I should get Glam no
for sure like and you should like guasha
and Ice roll like make sure you're
chiseled and snatched yeah maybe I'll do
like a little fast I'll bring a ring
light oh thank you that's good I'm gonna
be there so I'm excited yeah that'll be
really great but before we do any of
those Tings any of them we absolutely
must the fat Side Story is that you need
to know before you go to your office
Halloween party
I like that
um well today's episode is sponsored by
rothies rothies is back you guys we
obviously love Roth these and we have a
code we haven't had a code for a while
so pay attention please you guys I love
Roti so much and and they left us for a
while they did um and I never stopped
wearing my rothies I just want that to
be known I was wearing them yesterday
and that's a testament to the brand
because like one thing about us is like
we're bitter like oh you stopped
sponsoring I stop using rothies it's
impossible I couldn't quit them you
could couldn't quit them they're
actually the perfect I mean they're a
great shoe they're gorgeous they have so
many they're so comfortable but they're
also the perfect airport shoe because
they're a sneaker that's easy to get on
and off if you don't have a CSA
pre-check and you need to take your
shoes off right well that's a whole
other conversation that we must talk
about
um so if you're looking for versatile
shoes that are stylish and still and
still feel comfortable then shop at
rothies their signature seamless knit
design looks and feels great right out
of the box with no break-in period plus
transitioning to a new fall look is
super easy with rothy's shoes with so
many colors that work season after
season it's a no-brainer to wear a pair
so you may have heard of their shoes the
point and the flat from rothies but they
also make insanely comfortable sneakers
loafers ankle boots and more their wide
variety of styles are great for fall and
winter so you never have to worry about
getting brand new shoes each season the
best part is that everything rothies
makes is better for the planet they've
repurposed millions of water bottles
into their signature thread that goes
into every single one of their products
so of course some of the key takeaways
from what these are the Comfort if
you're in shoes all day you stand a lot
at work you walk around a lot at work
like your feet can really take a toll
and rock the these are so so comfortable
and they're washable which is so crazy
to me like the fact that not all shoes
are washable they should be right
whether you wear them in the rain or you
just like are tough on things like I am
like being able to throw them into the
washing machine
is perfect I gotta work it yeah again
and again so you can just literally
throw them in the washing machine and
they come out looking brand new which is
so crazy also if you have a propensity
towards a little flat-footedness so
Rockies can be quite comfortable on the
sole I I think my favorite brought these
is the loafer mine is the sneaker but
also the ballet flat little flat things
so cute get stylish shoes versatile and
durable enough to wear all the time with
rothies and get 20 off your first
purchase at rothies.com
TMT that's rothy's
r-o-t-h-y-s.com slash TMT now I feel
like I say this every time we do a Roth
these ad but literally the letters in
rothies with the exception of tea spell
ashrae yeah and I just think that's a
sign it's an anagram it makes you think
only superheroes
rothies
only spelling ashrae oh only superheroes
rothies yeah also an anagram is actually
not that and that acronym is what you're
thinking no no that's not what I was
saying like when something what's an
anagram maybe it is a word or phrase
found by rearranging the others oh okay
it is an anagram it is an anagram but I
made an acronym what's the thing that's
like saying backwards and forwards
palindrome yeah Hannah palindrome
Ava race car pop
wow Mom
hello are you okay
hello race car is a crazy one it's not
right yeah yeah it's simulation vibes
are you ready for the stories for the
stories I am ready I just think it goes
without set no it doesn't go without
saying it's worth mentioning like I'm
feeling particularly Delirious today
yeah I woke up I'm not right not right
not right yeah she came in while I was
already getting glammed and I said I
can't do it getting lambd by myself
sorry I made it seem more fabulous than
it was no you should have lied I was
doing my own makeup um she came in and
said she couldn't do it I I really can't
and they said Claudia it's gonna be
another great day of saving gen Z's and
I said okay and Bryce said yeah Claudia
you're so funny everyone needs to hear
you that is what Bryce said and Bryce
said you know after your kind of
award-winning takes this week on fat
phobia and cancel culture and Trigger
warnings
um you would be doing a disservice to
the people if you didn't get your
[ __ ] ass up and work that's what
Bryce said and that's really kind of
what put sometimes we just need a little
fire under our ass to get out of bed on
a Friday you know and the thing is Bryce
doesn't lie he doesn't he doesn't he
doesn't even when you want him to it's
like Bryce I look cute do these pants
make me look fat yes yes Mommy they do
because you are fat
okay first story Tom and Gisele will be
following filing for divorce today after
13 years of marriage people has
confirmed that they will both file in
Florida on Friday morning that is today
morning a source tells people to settle
into the courthouse it's in Florida yeah
oh my God that would be like courthouse
and then Spirit Halloween perfect list
of errands today this Source says the
settlement is all worked out they've
been working on the terms this whole
time they added that they agreed to
joint custody of the kids
okay who am I this is who am I right now
Bridget Moynihan
I'm feeling really happy for Bridget
like I'm just trying to find like a a
positive because this is you know the
destruction of one of America's greatest
couples you know so on the bright side
it's a great day to be Richard Moynihan
yes
it also emerged at Giselle Tom and
ultimatum like a few months ago being
like spend more time at home or I'm
going like no more football or I'm
leaving and obviously he shows in
football but what I've recently learned
is he's been stinking up the field have
you seen this yikes no I haven't been I
just the thing is I don't really keep up
with football and if I did I wouldn't
keep up with Tom Brady because it's like
yeah obviously he's going to be good
yeah no I saw a headline today like
three losses in a row which is like an
all-time low for him was it worth it Tom
and so it's like you really right like
you drop the ball literally in your
marriage and on the field right and you
had retired and you came back to stink
it up and you had retired after a win
which is the best way to go they won the
Super Bowl right no no
they won two years ago but last year
they didn't make it to the Super Bowl
and he retired so that's the thing like
with when you're the greatest retiring
the timing is so important because you
got to go out on a high and I feel like
when he first retired he did he won with
the Patriots
and that's the perfect way to go he
really just should have let sleeping
dogs lie yeah and especially if you're
going to come out of retirement again
just stink it up start winning yeah in a
big way yeah
um especially if you're gonna leave your
family and break and you know choose the
game over your right no I think that's
really not an unreasonable ask from
Giselle like it's not about money at
this point it's just about like being
obsessed with the game and you gotta Let
It Go like it's now it's time for family
I feel like the family has probably
sacrificed a lot to let Tom live his
dreams like they probably don't see
their dad that much he's always
traveling yada yada and now it's time
it's time you got to come home but maybe
he didn't want to come home maybe that
like highlights a problem in the
marriage you know but I feel like for a
lot of Wags it's like there is going to
be a period of time that you are going
to grind like the the highlight of your
career in your 20s 30s when you're at
Peak athleticism and I will hold it down
for you so that when you're done we can
be a family you will have built
something amazing and that's like the
trade-off yeah but if they never come
home then you get no trade-offs at what
point are you like well you didn't hold
up your end of the bargain Mall I've
been holding it down for you no it's so
right like I think in terms of the
divorce I'm probably gonna side with
Giselle
um however while I am sad that you know
this is the end of an Institutional
marriage I am genuinely looking forward
to seeing who they both date yeah like
they're both so good looking they both
run in fabulous Circles of people and I
think we could be getting like some I
mean I wouldn't be surprised if it was
like Gisele and Pete Davidson and Kim
and Tom like Kim and Tom like obsessed
obsessed Giselle and Brad Pitt yeah no
Giselle I feel like actually is
she's like two
I don't know what the right word is but
she's to something to date Pete Davidson
like she's too
do you know what word I'm looking for
I don't know if there's a word it's not
it's like a combination of like mature
set in her ways like
matronly but I don't mean that in like
an old way I mean in like a
sophisticated maybe sophisticated is the
word I'm looking for I don't think
she'll fall into that Trope but like so
many women before her right like I think
she'll State someone age-appropriate
Brad Pitt yeah but it's clear what she
wants is just like a partner a man who's
gonna be at home a family man yeah so
somebody who's not like a little kid or
somebody who's like at the point in
their career where they've already
peaked they've built something and now
they're just enjoying it she feels like
is the best part of being like a rich
ass celebrity like just enjoy like
couldn't be me you know you can't turn
it off no like it's it's hard obviously
Tom Brady would never be irrelevant well
actually Tom Brady is a different
example because he's dedicated his life
to like a sport right but think of like
all like his childhood like waking up
early going to college for sure practice
every single day and then literally for
30 years 40 years and then to have none
of it no but like that's the thing with
sports and I think that's what you're
prepared for is like at some point you
are limited by your body like you can't
play football in your 80s right you know
you can make movies in your 80s but you
can't like so everyone knows by the time
you get to like your late 30s and 40s
like the end is near so I feel like
you're preparing for that for a while so
for him to not let it go it's like hella
delusional honestly right so the end is
near but like he's still playing aside
from these last three games at you know
a top level so for sure I think the
whole point of like retiring is getting
the timing right like knowing yeah like
maybe I could do it a few more years I
wouldn't stink I would be good but like
knowing when the time is up right but so
then you retire but then you're sitting
around at home and it's like well I did
have a few more years in Me Maybe I
should go write them out but see most of
them don't retire and just sit at home
they become like sportscasters they
create businesses and Tom has uh like an
underwear company he has like a million
things going on he's like you know on
the boards of all these big companies
like if he wanted to get up and do
something every day he would have plenty
to do I feel like Tom Brady can't be a
sportscaster no no no no no definitely
not especially not like the year after
he's graduated because he's talking
about all the people that he played with
like I just I don't see that for him no
me neither you when you reach a certain
level
um you don't become a sportscaster did
Peyton Manning become a sportscaster I
feel like I see him on the TV sometimes
he's a personality a bit it yeah because
he's so funny and charming and like
America loves him like SNL and
Nationwide is on your side he does a
good job I don't think he's bored and
he's up there with the greats I also I
don't think he takes himself so
seriously I think Tom does
Jackie that's it that's totally it and
that's why people like Peyton he's so
like he's America's guy he's affable
yeah that's it affable affable
um I feel like
um
a good example is also like Terry
Bradshaw the Bradshaw bunch he was like
to my understanding like the best he
holds like tons of Records he's like
amazing
um
and even he isn't too good for reality
TV so right and I feel like a lot of
sportscasters are like we're a really
really good football players because
they're a lot or athletes because there
are so many athletes and not all of them
become but I do feel like you know Tom
Brady Aaron Rodgers no there is a level
you have to be in order to become a
successful successful sportscaster after
your professional sports career you have
to be like have recognizability to your
name like there's so many people who
play on teams like we've never heard of
so you need to have like name
recognizability but you have to be
underneath a certain level like and I
think a perfect example of who's a
really successful sportscaster right now
is Tony Romo he was great he's not going
to be like we're not going to remember
him in 50 years but he was very very
good America loved him he was like a
celebrity we all knew his name and now
he's a great sportscaster he was like
the perfect level for it yeah
but I agree Tom Brady's too famous yeah
I'm serious yeah but I also think he
kind of needs like to rehabilitate His
Image like I also think that sitting on
the boards of a lot of companies like
for him is boring is yeah boring but
he's like he you know he's out here
thirst monstering like he has all these
companies and he gets like tick tockers
and he does makes Tick Tock with the
tick tockers to like promote his like
athleisure like he does stuff he should
like coach his kids a local sports team
also he's a dad so that is a full-time
job full-time right so but he should
like coach yeah I mean that would
definitely be unfair but for sure
it is what it is it is what it is I'm
just saying like plenty of amazing
sports players go on to live fulfillment
fulfilling retirements of course but I
do think it is a difficult transition
for sure just like anything in life
fascinating transition wait that's a
Shrek Kimmy Schmidt oh the end of the
theme song oh yeah where they remix that
guy it could have been Shrek though
sounds like um donkey for sure
because it's the same intonation as and
in the morning I'm making waffles yeah
yeah
um so machine Tom and Giselle the best
truly divorce is hard sounds like they
have their terms all with rich people
like famous people they take care of
that [ __ ] like I don't think it's going
to be like messy I want this house you
get that house I feel like everything is
in separate names separate businesses
and if they settled everything before
they filed then that's what the
messiness of the last few months has
been and now maybe it will be smooth
sailing smooth sailing totally yeah I
wonder where Gisele will choose to live
now that she can live anywhere right
they lived in Boston for a while then in
Florida and they have houses all over
yeah we'll see we'll see are you ready
for our next story yes let the good
times roll Elon Musk tweets after his
first official day of his Twitter
takeover so Elon Musk walked into
Twitter HQ the other day with the
kitchen sink and he is tweeting up a
storm saying the bird has been he's
actually not tweeting that much I went
to his Twitter to like see he was like
tweeting all about SpaceX I'm like sir
you have another company yeah totally
but he said that he's freed the bird
um a couple of top Executives have been
fired with some golden parachutes 204
million dollars in total for three
Executives who were fired I'm sorry what
yeah 200 million dollars to get fired
yeah should have worked at Twitter
um so I actually wanted I was looking at
his Twitter he released a statement on
like why he did this which I thought was
really helpful because I feel like
everyone's speaking for him about him
and why did he do it honestly I like
totally forgot about this Saga because
like there was all this drama he was
going to do it and then they accepted
and they rejected it and then I was like
all right I guess it's not happening and
then it just happened and then he was
forced to complete the purchase like
they went to court oh did they yeah I
missed that whole thing and so now he's
embracing his new role so he released
like a full statement explaining why he
wanted to buy Twitter which I thought
was helpful I'll read it I wanted to
reach out personally to share my
motivation in acquiring Twitter there
has been much speculation about why
about Twitter and what I think about
advertising most of it has been wrong
the reason I acquired Twitter is because
it is important to the future of
civilization to have a common digital
Town Square where a wide range of
beliefs can be debated in a healthy
manner without resorting to violence
there's currently great danger that
social media will Splinter into far
right wing and far left-wing Echo
chambers that generate more hate and
divide our society in the Relentless
pursuit of clicks much of traditional
media has fueled and catered to those
polarized extremes as they believe that
that is what brings in the money but in
doing so the opportunity for dialogue is
lost that's why I bought Twitter I
didn't do it because it would be easy I
didn't do it to make more money I did it
to try and help Humanity whom I love and
I do so with humility recognizing that
failure in pursuing this goal despite
our best efforts is a very real
possibility that said Twitter obviously
cannot become a free-for-all hellscape
where anything can be said with no
consequences in addition to adhering to
the laws of the land our platform must
be warm and welcoming to all where you
can choose your desired experience
according to your preferences just as
you can choose for example to see movies
or play video games ranging from all
ages to mature that's it
um so I feel like that does make sense
like when you think about how like now
social media like new apps pop up like
and it's four different people with the
same views and it's like we're all just
talking if you want to talk about if you
want to talk to people who agree with
you on this subject you can open this
app and if you want to talk to people so
the concept that he's looking for like a
civilized Town Square it does make sense
I do feel as though it's like wishful
thinking but I commend him on the effort
yeah I think it's great I mean I think
that there's so much censorship on
social media of course like hate speech
should never be tolerated when he says
like it will abide by the laws of the
land like that is the law of the land
like we have freedom of speech that
doesn't cover that doesn't cover hate
speech or threatening speech or threats
of violence so that same law would be
applied to Twitter and I think it's
great and I think when it comes to
censorship it's like if someone tweets
something or says something that's
misinformation or not true it's like
it's not helpful to delete it and censor
it and no one should ever see that bad
information it's more helpful if someone
with the facts counters what like debate
that's interesting yeah healthy debate I
know that that is a concept because God
has been completely lost and that's what
Elon is trying to bring back also I mean
so many things just get completely wiped
from Twitter like mainstream social
media and a lot of times they're labeled
as misinformation but like we've seen
that eventually it actually wasn't
misinformation so the thing is is like I
don't know if Elon purchasing Twitter
can ameliorate the fact that like civil
discourse in our society is gone like
and it's it's nice wishful thinking that
like yeah maybe we can make it happen on
Twitter but I don't think that's
possible because as human beings in this
country like I think we're incapable no
I don't think that now all of a sudden
like civil discourse will be solved and
people will learn how to have an
argument and talk to each other
respectfully but I think that all points
of view aside from hate speech
threatening speech violence Etc deserve
to have a foreign and people who are
genuinely in the pursuit of information
can read all sides no and it's like an
even playing field yeah yeah no I agree
I agree and I think that the but I don't
think it's gonna change the culture no
better no I don't think so but I think
that the road that we were headed down
and that we probably still are going
down like is not good yeah and
I think that this is a positive thing
yeah no we'll we'll see I don't think I
don't know I don't know how it could be
worse than what's been done that's true
I did see people we really can't get
worse I saw pictures of Elon at the
office everyone loving Elon having
coffee with Elon asking Elon questions
must be a crazy time to work at Twitter
which I don't think there really has
ever been like an amazing time you know
yeah no I think there's a crazy time I
think it is a crazy time I think a lot
of also employees are not happy about
Elon coming in yeah for sure well that's
just like but I'm sure there are a lot
of employees who are happy like you know
like either
I mean I don't think every employee
likes their boss like right but we just
happen to know who your boss is because
he's famous yeah but um
we'll see I just think it's very
interesting the landscape constantly
shifting shifting stress ends shifting
streisands this is a big shift though
but yeah I think it'll be an interesting
thing to watch a fascinating transition
huh it's gonna be today's all about
fascinating transitions yeah
it really is total title
next story crazy news
SNL star Chris red was reportedly
punched with brass knuckles at comedy
seller holy [ __ ] yeah Comedian Chris red
was sucker punch in the face with brass
knuckles according to a new report an
unknown assailant attacked the attack
the SNL Alum outside of Comedy Cellar in
New York City on Wednesday night
resulting in red being hospitalized and
it turns out the attacker used the
illegal defense weapon TMZ reported
sources close to Red told the outlet the
attack left him with two black eyes and
a gash on his nose that required
stitches he's reportedly working with
police to help identify suspects using
surveillance footage the authorities
have gathered
so it's unclear whether this was like an
attack on stage or like maybe it was
someone it wasn't unsage it was outside
of the comedy seller so was it just like
crazy New York Shenanigans unclear but
the person Insider said the man had been
waiting outside the club for an hour oh
waiting for him yeah and then page six
said that the comedy World believes that
the attack has to do with Chris dating
Keenan's estranged wife however there's
nothing to suggest that he would that
Keenan was personally involved in the
The Comedy world that's what the comedy
world thinks um no I don't think that's
it like honestly this is [ __ ] like
diabolical like if somebody went to his
show and like waited for him outside
because like he either didn't like
something he said that's [ __ ] crazy
like that's literally so scary and
I just feel like this is the
like the third or fourth instinct
instance instance oh thank you so much
um of like comedians being attacked in
like the last year
yeah I forget we just were talking about
oh Dave Chappelle somebody stormed the
with a knife
um there was another incident and now
this I don't know Chris Rock well of
course I don't know if this has to do
with
or is it like a personal Vendetta I
don't know so uh it's you can't really
speak on it until you know but like
that's really sad brass knuckles is like
so scary yeah and people are not okay no
no no they're not really truly people
are not [ __ ] okay like for real
and I just think it's time we all like
spoke about that more like the not
okayness of people um
it's astounding
yeah I'm wishing him the best like Get
Well reflection yeah and hopefully he'll
be able to identify his assailant
Injustice could potentially be served
potentially are you ready for our next
story only if it's the next story that's
sponsored by Bruce
is an electric toothbrush that will
change the way you think about brushing
your teeth with powerful Sonic
technology and Ultra Gentle bristles the
brush redefines what it means to have
super clean teeth it's like that feeling
when you just leave the dentist a fresh
whole mouth clean but every single day
so when you get Bruce which we both have
we've had for years now I actually have
one down here that I because I spent so
much time here I can't really be living
without my brush you get the brush kit
and here's what's included in it the
electric toothbrush three brush heads a
magnetic charging station and a Sleek
travel case
um there's so many things that are
really great about the brush but I think
one of the best is the price because
electric toothbrushes are kind of
expensive like some of them go up to 200
the brush is really affordable for an
electric toothbrush and it's really
stunning too it's not like this big ugly
piece of like furniture that sits on
your counter it's Sleek it comes in
different colors you can get one to
match your counters I have magenta and
like a pale Millennial pink
um the Sonic technology that it uses is
industry leading it produces 42 000
brush Strokes per minute which is 300
times
300 brush Strokes per minute and helps
with deep cleaning and in those hard to
reach places the battery life lasts an
entire 30 days on a full charge which is
making it perfect for travel and it
keeps your countertop cord free so get
20 off when you pick your Bruce brush
kit and plan when you go to brush.com
toast that's 20 off when you go to brush
b-r-u-u-s-h.com slash toast Yeah
chris.com Toast yeah yeah we love douche
I just switched to my new seasonal fall
color because I was I love my Millennial
pink of course but I wanted some fresh
Optics in my bag some autumnal Vibes
autumnal vibes are you ready for our
next story Bachelor in Paradise alums
Joe AKA grocery store Joe Mary Serena
Pitt in a courthouse wedding cute so the
two of them got married Thursday at New
York City's City Hall they stunned fans
when they posted an Instagram video of
their nuptials nearly one year before
their original wedding day next
September so they said just married we
are still having a wedding this
September but who doesn't want to get
married twice they also shared a full
one minute and 50 second video of the
ceremony on their YouTube channel uh not
sure if you sir sure if you saw pictures
I did see a picture
um they're both wearing masks and so is
there a vision and like honestly like
for me I'm like so like triggered by the
side
I know honestly if it was me like I
would have waited till next September
just so I didn't have to have videos
like I don't want I don't want this time
in my life memorialized you know what I
mean no one thousand percent are they
still making people wear masks in New
York City's City Hall no
the Mandate was lifted so I guess if
you're wearing it you're just wearing it
because you choose to so that maybe this
photo wouldn't bother you but like for
me like when we were like when we had to
wear masks like I understood why but
like I hated every minute of it and the
minute we were free I always looked back
like literally Girls Gone Wild taking my
bikini top off also like it's worth
saying there's no one else around no I
know it's like silly
um but I don't think it bothers them
which is good because it's their wedding
it's not mine
um but it was my first thought of course
as well and my second thought was if
anyone was watching Love is Blind I
don't know if anybody's made this call
yet but there's a guy on it called Cole
um and he's literally grocery store Joe
like they're the same person they have
like the same smile the same hair the
same body and like the same like you
know like silly disposition you know
like silliness that's so cute did anyone
else think that sound off in the
comments sound off um when I first heard
that they were married I was actually
really surprised because I feel like a
lot of Bachelor couples get engaged and
then don't get married period or for a
really long time so I thought that this
was really sweet
um and then I saw this picture and and
um I was a little depressed like
I was a little depressed by like
honestly it's so depressing no because
like and it looks like a picture like
out of 2020 and it's like it's 2022 like
you're getting married no I know take it
off no I know I look I for what I really
do think like criticizing people's
wedding photos is like the meanest this
isn't a wedding photo but it's not a
wedding photo so nevertheless she
presents by the way if they're wedding
photos if like in their September
wedding where like they would make more
sense for them to wear a mask at their
real wedding with 300 people right but
if they had pictures with that
math again no it was the first thing I
saw because they're like so bright blue
and like I feel like City Hall photos
like the whole concept of City Hall is
that it's like it's like a drab
government building but in a way it's
become like really romanticized in the
last couple years like celebrities were
always going like you can make the
pictures like really kind of like iconic
like Joe and uh Sophie Turner like they
did it at a chapel like you can get
dressed up and like make it fun and like
have a photographer
um but the mask it did really like
depress me yeah to a whole new level I
didn't need them to get all dressed up
and have a photographer
um I don't know how romantic City Hall
is no like you can make you know what I
mean I mean yeah I mean Stoners I look
stunning you wear like a pink coat to
the floor yeah and a white dress no I
mean I wore a Halloween costume a zombie
breast a zombie bride ex-wife
um and I like I had fun with it and so
whatever like happy for them I don't
want to be a nice hair so let's just
know I'm really actually thrilled for
them that they ain't married I think
they're a nice couple especially because
was he engaged to Kendall yes she must
be vomiting and they were engaged for a
long time so like he got engaged to
Serena like this is it in their mouth
and I think that that part is really
sweet and they really say like if you
have nothing nice to say don't say
anything no I have so many nice things
to say about these two getting married
to the real running photos but like I
have the picture was triggering the yeah
the masks were triggering I agree with
no masks oh my God I would have been
like that is so cute yeah no and like
explained like I'm really not trying to
be like so negative but like so then
they're like you can kiss the bride so
they took their masks off so like what
so when you're kissing your bride Kobe
can't get you like it just made no sense
no and also like if we want to get
nitpicky like his mask is under his nose
so like really what are you doing yeah
your mask is under your nose Joe no like
so then what point is it serving other
than ruining your pictures right maybe
it's just like that they were gonna like
I don't know anything about them so I
don't want to like
like suggest maybe they had covid
actually no they wouldn't leave their
house if they had covered maybe they had
coven that's why they have to wear a
mask no I don't think they would I think
if they had covered they would wait a
week to go to City Hall it's not like
you know
I don't know maybe this is three people
who have coveted no way getting married
in isolation oh maybe well if they're in
isolation they all have covered they
don't have to wear a mask
happy for you know that I am
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story I really am it's an
interesting one I'm looking forward to
getting your take because Harry Hamlin
and his daughter Delilah weird weird
are disturbing fans with their quote
creepy quote provocative photo all right
not provocative just like a little
strange because maybe this conversation
doesn't apply to me because my dad is
dead but I would literally never take a
photo like that with my father like it's
beyond so the picture in question was
snapped last month at New York Fashion
Week but it recently made its way to
Instagram where users expressed their
many concerns the image shows the actor
70 standing closely next to the model
daughter 24 while grabbing her tightly
by the lower waist in the sheer top
Delilah's scene staring staring
seductively at the camera while her
while her father intensely presses his
face against the side of hers yep that's
exactly what's happening here it's weird
again like Google it but
it's really weird it looks like a couple
like that is the exact type of photo you
would take if you were like a really
steamy and in love it's like MGK and
negative yeah
so it's weird I think we should talk
about how weird it is and I don't like
it I don't like it one bit I don't like
it it's as my people would say Zillow
covered
it's not respectful it's not nice no no
it's not it's [ __ ] weird
and maybe this like you can just chalk
it up to like Hollywood weirdness but
I'm a human being and I think it's weird
no I don't think that's like how like I
don't think that's the difference
between like Hollywood and light people
no it like reminds me like when Megan no
not Megan Angelina Jolie like made out
with her brother like it's weird
yeah
it doesn't remind me of that but it was
weird nonetheless
yeah check it out for yourself
um let us know what you think but I
think the general consensus is weird
yeah inappropriate
not right not
father Lee conduct conduct
people asked if this was a scene from
House of the track no I'm I'm distressed
by this I'm deeply distressed it's
to put it simply it ain't right it's
simply it's too stressing I'm distressed
and to put it simply this photo is
distressing yeah so
um
yeah it's really weird I have no further
comment no like what else can you say
like we could we could you know
speculate like maybe he was turning his
head and they caught him in a bit
because you know they take a lot of
pictures for every second so like maybe
he sneezed to like scratch his nose on
her cheek or something I don't know like
maybe we could speculate about how this
is like not how they act and it was just
caught in a moment that's always my MO
is like to scratch my nose no to try and
find like another way that these two
could have fallen into this position but
I really am stumped yeah I'm stumped
yeah they've stumped me what can I say
you know and I'm actually speechless
which is really something for me because
there's nothing else that you can really
say besides this is so [ __ ] weird
like
it's so weird and I actually like really
liked Delilah Bell and Harry so this is
not a statement on them as people like
it's just simple to put it simply it's
weird
I think it's very simple yes not
complicated at all though she's
embracing the red hair trend which you
know what let's pivot is a big Trend now
yes celebrities influencers mostly who
have like dark hair are I mean a Stanton
has it now everyone is dying their hair
red well Delilah was like blondish yeah
yeah no no but like the trend is like
for everyone's copying like Kendall
Jenner like when she was in Milan dark
hair girly going to like a dark red
everyone is going red is is Kendall the
inspo for them I think so
cool I think so how does it make you
feel it's like a natural redhead I mean
we could also ask the boys because
there's the stripes Brethren they're
natural
um I mean if I feel great like cool like
that it's cool that being red-headed is
so cool but it's like the
um like what we were talking about
yesterday like agua fresca Spa water
it's like Kendall Jenner is the
inspiration right what about us natural
redheads no we've been living with this
for our whole life oh that's fair that's
totally it doesn't actually bother me
but that's just [ __ ] weird yeah no I
think um
I think there's something like obviously
everyone dyes their hair but I think
there's something about like permanently
dyeing your hair red that's like really
dishonest no like about acting as though
you are a redhead when you're not right
I never thought about it but you were
saying that to me and I guess I think
there's something like deeply fraudulent
about it I can't explain it yeah I just
think it's like usually pretty
impossible to to get a uh to get away
with dyed red hair and people think it's
natural right because it's so hard if
you can it's really hard to like
replicate like red hair color even the
people who are dying it now like it does
look dyed yeah so if you're able to pass
as a natural redhead like good for you
in your color no that's true that's true
it's a testament to all your hard work
right no that's true and your coloring
must have not been that far off yes if
the rest of you like makes sense like a
natural redhead that's very true like
you were saying that Amy Adams isn't a
natural redhead yes I was saying but she
has like she has this other natural red
hair and the coloring so that doesn't
bother me you yeah no we went on like uh
we were just talking about this for some
reason at like the dining room table
Yeah because we were talking about how
everyone's you guys were asking me how I
feel about everyone being a redhead now
so we just went on like a Google search
of like celebrities who are naturally
red and celebrities who are not and it
was really interesting
um Jessica Chastain is a natural girly
Isla Fisher isn't that true girly right
style is Howard is natural Madeleine
petch Christina Hendricks but then there
were Julie Roberts is like technically a
natural redhead then there were some
people on there who you would think were
natural redheads who are not and some
people who you wouldn't think are
natural redheads but they are right like
Nicole Kidman yes she's a natural
redhead someone who is not a natural
redhead but you would think they are
Sophie Turner and Amy Adams yeah it was
an interesting conversation but redhead
is definitely the name on everybody's
lips
maybe I'm really like genesis
inspiration after all perhaps perhaps
maybe it's all the tick tocks like I'm
subtly influencing
perhaps or it's just JC Murray
is she natural redhead
I well right now her hair is a shade of
red that it wasn't before because I feel
like it
it was more like strawberry blondish and
now she's like darker I think they're
calling it like pumpkin spice red so she
has like the complexion and the coloring
that like she's
would be I wouldn't even question that
she's a natural redhead you know yeah
and if she's not like she is because she
did a good job after coloring and she's
living life as a redhead
um and I'm gonna be living life as a
girly on the weekends because it is
officially the weekend that is the end
of your episode today and don't don't
smile because it's over nope don't frown
because it's over smile because it
happened yes and
we're gonna make those cookies we're
gonna make cookies this weekend we're
gonna go trick-or-treating in the
neighborhood we're gonna get ready for
our Monday toaster weed we're gonna get
our costumes ready we're gonna be with
brodini we're gonna be with Kayla we're
gonna be with Levi we didn't even talk
about how Olivia officially released the
name of her baby baby showing pictures
on her Instagram to go check it out and
it's just gonna be gorgeous gorgeous
weekend of saving the bees
another wonderful weekend of saving the
Streisand Brethren thank you guys so
much for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the first five stories that you did you
know before you wake up and take a bite
at every morning toast we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
we found so it's Spotify iTunes teacher
public video I hope we do castbox all
the places where we listen to the
podcast find us the toasty by five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
wickedly talented we are
hope you guys have an amazing weekend
enjoy Halloween be safe don't take candy
from strangers watch out for Fenton all
describe the candy for real people
watching and also if you have kids they
are disguising fentanyl as Smarties
there's enough fentanyl in this country
to kill so many people and if you're
gonna be out like partying and like you
want to partake in drugs be safe be
smart don't take [ __ ] from people and
test that [ __ ] okay check your kids
candy give them things that are wrapped
that literally couldn't be anything
other than that candy like the two
um
like we like this is [ __ ] you know
English is really hard right like you're
the I'm like if you're gonna go do drugs
make sure you like do you guys need any
snacks condoms let me know like if
you're gonna do drugs and I really do
that and you're like you're gonna do
drugs I forgot that you do it in the
house 100 get strips get fentanyl
testing strips like B don't be stupid
that's a different issue just like
fentanyl in drugs and like but a
separate issue is Halloween candy
fentanyl disguised as Halloween candy
that they're passing up they look like
Smarties they really look like candy so
seriously check your kids bin check them
in
um thank you guys have a great weekend
happy Halloween bye happy Halloween